[Musica]
mi ha sempre stuzzicato il tema del
rapporto fra l'essere e il potere
l'essere è quella dimensione eterna di
ciò che sta e non cade non cambia non si
corrompe in altro da sé non diventa
nulla
il potere invece è quell essere che può
che diviene che si trasforma che
annienta le due parole sono molto vicine
il potere per la nostra tradizione una
specificazione dell'essere tant'è che il
latino i due verbi sono molto simili
esse e posse e così il tema dell'essere
e del potere è il tema del rapporto tra
il tempo fermo eterno e il tempo che
passa che si trasforma e dentro il
rapporto fra queste visioni del tempo si
giocano i destini dei nostri sistemi
politici noi intuiamo l'eternità del
tempo abbiamo sprazzi di questa visione
ma inconsapevolmente ci sembra evidente
che il tempo sia tutt'altro che eterno
passi corrompa le cose sia caducità
annichilimento morte sia per la nostra
esistenza singola che per le nostre
società
la visione del tempo come annientamento
genera gran parte delle nostre
istituzioni sono il tentativo di
contrastare questa minaccia senza una
dimensione politica noi siamo a rischio
di morte costantemente siamo a rischio
degli attacchi dei nostri simili di
doversela cavare da soli contro le forze
della natura o del caso la gente quando
si lamenta anche a ragione della
politica perde di vista a volte questa
sua caratteristica nella politica vi è
una dimensione salvifica è quella
dimensione a cui ci alleiamo e in cui ci
alleiamo gli uni agli altri per
permanere nell'esistenza per stare e non
a caso quando parliamo dei nostri
sistemi politici
utilizziamo soprattutto termini che
derivano dal verbo greco sistemi lo
stare istituzione sistema costituzione
status statista resistenza stato le
costituzioni fondano sistemi giuridici e
costituiscono gli stati ma cosa c'è
dietro uno stato che cosa realmente
fonda il sistema politico vi propongo di
pensare insieme oggi che dietro ad uno
stato ci sia un istante curioso no
questa parola che indica qualcosa che
noi leghiamo al tempo e viene anch'essa
dagli stemmi ma noi non esploriamo con
consapevolezza la valenza politica
mi piacerebbe darvi l'idea di questo
istante non solo come un momento
puntuale nel tempo non come una durata
breve come la lama della ghigliottina
che recide il collo del reo lunga come
un'intera guerra d'indipendenza
ma proprio come quel momento in cui
qualcosa che è sentito essere importante
sta e si pone è un qualcosa con cui fare
i conti
eli istante e questo istante è
importante perché porta con sé qualcosa
che cosa un'istanza top un'altra parola
che deriva la iss temi che usiamo spesso
ma che ancora se non a cui non
riconosciamo alcun significato politico
forte dunque l'istante porta con sé un
istanza questa istanza si costituisce in
sistema questo sistema si fa stato cioè
lo stato è un'istanza che si fa sistema
è inoltre lo stato e ciò che rimane di
un istante il ricordo di un istante che
è stato che nel momento in cui si fa
stato è già passato
e infatti ogni struttura di potere vive
un conflitto con il tempo che sta con il
presente perché lo stato passa
attraverso altri stanti che presentano
altre istanze la sua fondazione diventa
sempre più un ricordo che si svuota dei
sentimenti che l'hanno sostenuto e ha
consentito e con esso sbiadisce anche la
sua legittimità o se volete possiamo
pensarla da un altro punto di vista
secondo me è più esatto lo stato vive
già da sempre costantemente nell'istanza
noi viviamo nel presente la vita dello
stato avviene nell'istante ma non in
maniera consapevole
siamo noi e chi governa ma noi perché
bisogna parlare di noi non di loro
poiché poi quando andiamo noi a
governare facciamo gli stessi errori
per ora siamo noi che non siamo in grado
di vedere radicalmente le cose in questa
maniera e comportarci di conseguenza
noi e chi governa i nostri sistemi chi
di noi governo i nostri sistemi non
siamo in grado di comprendere
adeguatamente le istanze che ci si fanno
innanzi ad integrarle parliamo spesso di
integrità
diciamo che i nostri politici devono
essere integri i pubblici uffici
l'integrità dello stato uno stato
integro è uno stato che integra le
istanze che gli si fanno dinnanzi
altrimenti chiudendo le porte i o i
porti per qualcuno difendendo lo status
quo
lo stato si disintegra o se volete un
sinonimo si corrompe un rompere rompe il
cum il coni il legame che ci tiene
insieme e che già da sempre tiene
insieme
nell'istante lo stato e l'istanza ok ora
basta portare avanti questi ragionamenti
perché mi rendo conto che stamattina
lavando i denti non è esattamente quello
che pensavate di fare per rilassarvi
quello che potremmo chiamare
un'ontologia della politica
ci basterà sapere che lo stato quindi
devere istituzionalizzarsi nell'istanza
ri attualizzarsi in ogni istante che
porti con sé qualcosa di importante
rifarsi presente per essere legittimo ma
come agisce questa struttura ontologica
dal punto di vista psicologico come sono
i comportamenti politici di chi vede il
presente come una minaccia se non
riusciamo a vedere il presente come
portatore di novità salvifica
se non riusciamo a fare spazio alle sue
istanze se pensiamo che in passato sia
stato possibile afferrare il potere una
volta per tutte non vediamo che il
potere non è mai afferrabile non è mai
in uno stato delle cose ma è sempre
ancora in quell'istante che sta per
sopraggiungere se pensiamo che il potere
possa essere posseduto è l'ossessione
crediamo di avere qualcosa che in realtà
è altrove ci chiudiamo per conservare
gelosamente il nulla sospettiamo che chi
ci sta intorno ci voglia derubare
vediamo nemici ovunque fantasmi e la
paranoia ci neghiamo la gioia
dell'apertura
e così da sempre chi ha il potere
governa fa i conti con questo
incantesimo l'incantesimo del tempo che
passa e che annienta e si chiude al
posto di aprirsi e lesivi che abbiamo
conosciuto fino adesso hanno tentato di
rinnovare la loro legittimità in molte
maniere ai nuovi fallimentari sanguinose
a volte le lotte per la successione al
trono poi le rivoluzioni poi le
restaurazioni colpi di stato e la nostra
democrazia liberale e rappresentativa
che ha le sue forme di resistenza al
tempo le elezioni l'alternanza le
riforme anche costituzionali ma anche la
democrazia rappresentativa che sembrava
assecondare questo dinamismo meglio di
altri regimi è a rischio di entrare
rapidamente in crisi quando i governi
politici si chiudono al posto di
ascoltare
quando i partiti non rappresentano più
la società civile e le procedure
democratiche risultano inadatte e lente
a filtrare le istanze in un mondo sempre
più veloce e la tecnica può aiutare la
democrazia di fronte alla democrazia si
aprono due strade da un lato la post
democrazia in cui le procedure
democratiche sono svuotate di senso e
nascondono forme di elitarismo di
controllo del consenso
dall'altro un potenziamento della
democrazia una democratizzazione della
democrazia che possa di nuovo rispondere
alle esigenze di rappresentazione della
società e contemporaneamente a quelle di
efficacia decisionale la tecnica in
questo caso la rivoluzione digitale
aumenta il livello della potenza la
posta in gioco ma può essere funzionale
a tutte e due queste strade può essere
cambridge analitica può influenzare le
campagne elettorali può essere
l'utilizzo di grandi massi di dati ed
informazioni per centralizzare il
controllo e il potere sui cittadini e
potenze non democratiche utilizzano il
digitale come strumento per creare
egemonia culturale nei loro paesi
ed è la stessa cosa che le forze non
democratiche fanno da noi si utilizzano
i dati per fare sentiment analysis si
individuano i temi le paure che
percorrono il web si utilizzano questi
queste paure per fabbricare messaggi
fake news che facciano leva su questo si
inondano i social con questi messaggi
che vengono ripetuti da botto da account
falsi
fino a quando non si crea un effetto
gregge per cui la gente accetta una cosa
vera solo perché è ripetuta da
moltissimi oppure il digitale può essere
messo al servizio dell'apertura della
relazione della trasparenza
del governo aperto quella forma di
governo che si apre ai cittadini a
mettere in trasparenza i dati e le
informazioni che lo riguardano
invitando i cittadini a controllare a
interagire a influenzare le scelte dei
governanti
io naturalmente propendo per
quest'ultima strada essendo un attivista
di questa evoluzione della democrazia ma
la tecnica il digitale di per sé non
garantirà che una delle due strade venga
prese al posto dell'altra lascerà questa
ambivalenza intatta si offrirà anche a
chi vorrà servirsene con
spregiudicatezza l'utilizzo del web e
dei dati nella logica di funzionamento
dei nostri sistemi democratici è una
cosa enorme di là da venire nel nostro
piccolo con parliament watch italia
tentiamo di coinvolgere pubblica
amministrazione in questi percorsi di
apertura di mettere i cittadini in grado
di monitorare pezzi di spesa pubblica
tentiamo di tirare fuori i dati che
riguardano gli appalti di coinvolgere i
cittadini a interessarsi a quello che
succede con i loro soldi tentiamo di
fare sistema con altre associazioni con
le quali sviluppiamo ragionamenti e
strumenti per rendere significativi
questi dati oppure con le associazioni
attive sul territorio che possono
raccontarci le loro storie le loro
battaglie le loro istanze
o ancora liberiamo dati e informazioni
su leggi che ci incuriosiscono come
quella sul bilancio partecipato in
sicilia
lo sapevate che ogni anno ogni comune
siciliano deve spendere con forme di
democrazia partecipata il 2 per cento
dei soldi che la regione gli trasferisce
se no li deve restituire l'anno dopo
molti soldi tornano indietro
noi mettiamo i cittadini in condizione
di rendersi conto di ciò che succede di
fare proposte di chiedere interazioni al
proprio comune col digitale
il digitale deve dunque essere
interattivo ma non nel senso che deve
essere il veicolo delle nostre relazioni
virtuali deve fare esplodere le nostre
relazioni reali deve aumentare la nostra
presenza nella realtà la nostra presenza
nel sistema politico
la nostra presenza nello stato e allora
ce ne potremmo fregare di prendere il
potere perché esprimeremo potere e
dunque il digitale non ci salverà di per
sé ma nella misura in cui sarà messo al
servizio di una visione una visione del
tempo presente e della politica che
iniziamo ad intuire ma che ancora non
abbiamo del tutto una visione del tempo
che verrà quando il digitale sarà un
mezzo forte per esprimere il presente
le nostre istanze per fare risaltare le
nostre relazioni è la nostra presenza
che riporterà lo stato all'istante e il
tempo della democrazia digitale giungerà
quando ognuno di noi sarà presente